Gary McKinnon was obsessed with UFOs and
believe governments were covering up
evidence that UFOs exist in the year
2000 he decided to do a little digging
Gary was a computer expert so what
better place to dig than on U.S
government computers what he found was
so shocking that it sent the entire
United States government into a
full-blown panic in fact the U.S spent
10 years trying to prosecute Gary he was
looking at 70 years in federal prison
but what information did Gary find that
could cause the US government to become
so aggressive please say aliens please
say aliens aliens
[Music]
Gary McKinnon's stepfather was into
science fiction and space travel and
this rubbed off on Gary when he was only
12 years old he joined bufora the
British UFO research Association but it
all came together when Gary was 13 and
had his own UFO sighting he saw a bright
red light in the sky that went from
Horizon to Horizon in about five seconds
at first he thought it was a meteor but
it was moving too slowly and erratically
he said it moved through the sky in a
waving motion like a dolphin bouncing in
and out of the water oh you know what
space Dolphins move that way on purpose
really I only said because they wanted
to see him make a face like he smelled
the foot as time went on Gary became
convinced that governments around the
world especially the United States
government had evidence that UFOs and
aliens were real but this evidence was
being withheld from the population of
course they withhold it and thank God
they do well we'd be out of a jab Amen
to that well Gary McKinnon was an expert
in computers and networking and worked
as a systems administrator even though
he was good at his job he was bored with
it his real passion was UFOs a passion
that was becoming an obsession and if
the government was hiding information
about UFOs he was going to do something
about it Idol fins on a Devil's
Playground that's something I teach you
on my guppies Gary knew that both NASA
and the U.S Department of Defense used
Windows which he described as a
operating system using skills he learned
as assisted men he wrote a program to do
one simple thing check the passwords of
all computers on a network he wanted to
know if they used the word password as a
password or if they used no password at
all his program ran for a year and found
hundreds of wide open government
computers to this day he insists he
wasn't hacking or attacking the computer
systems he said it was more like going
fishing for information
that phrase is a microaggression save it
for Twitter eventually Gary found
computers inside the U.S Navy U.S space
command and NASA but he didn't find
anything interesting until he stumbled
across aliens not exactly what did he
find he found a spreadsheet sometimes he
was so disappointing
[Music]
Gary McKinnon had accessed some of the
most highly classified files in the US
government most of what he found was
pretty boring lots of Staff reports
Department memos mostly just
bureaucratic paperwork but Gary found a
spreadsheet on a US Navy server that
caught his eye it was called
non-terrestrial officers and contained a
list of names he was looking at a list
of people's stations somewhere other
than planet Earth the non-terrestrial
offices could be humans serving on
another planet oh a non-human serving on
his planning well that's true but in
this case Gary was pretty sure that
these were humans because the list
showed officer transfers from one ship
to another so Gary looked for the ships
in the U.S naval registry let me guess
the ships wear it on the list they were
not
they appeared to belong to a secret
Fleet a fleet operating in space but
that wasn't even the most interesting
thing that he found a spreadsheet is
just words but you know what's worth a
thousand of those a picture a picture
Gary McKinnon had heard the testimony of
a woman named Donna Hare she was a
former NASA employee who worked at the
agency for years she said she saw quite
a few UFOs in NASA satellite photos but
the photos both physical and digital
were always altered to remove the UFOs
from the images oh you don't say in the
1980s Donna was working for NASA at
Johnson Space Center specifically she
worked in the highly secure area known
as building number eight one day Donna
stopped by a co-worker's office about
something completely different when she
walked in this co-worker had a satellite
image on his computer screen he showed
her a white cigar-shaped object he asked
her what she thought it could be she
said it might be a blob on the Emulsion
or a scanning defect but then he pointed
to something that made Donna have to
catch her breath the object was casting
a shadow on the ground so whatever it
was it was real Gary was intrigued by
the story and thought Donna Hare was
telling the truth since he already had
access to NASA's computers he wrote a
program to search for the image he
narrowed his list of hundreds of
computers down to just a few inside
building number eight naturally they had
blank passwords so he logged into them
one by one most of these machines had
empty desktops but one computer had
folders named raw filtered processed and
unprocessed this was exactly how Donna
described the computer in building
number eight so this was the one the
folder labeled unprocessed contained an
image but the file was huge so Gary
couldn't download it so he tried to view
it on the remote desktop so Gary
McKinnon clicked the file and watched as
the image appeared pixel by pixel line
by line at first he saw nothing but
blank space but then the hemisphere of
the planet began to form and then he saw
clouds and then about two-thirds of the
way down he saw what he was looking for
a spaceship
Gary saw a large silver cylinder
completely smooth no rivets or seams of
any kind but a few seconds after opening
the file Gary noticed the mouse on the
remote computer move but he wasn't
moving it uh-oh The Jig Is up whoever
was sitting at the computer in building
number eight turned off their network
connection and Gary was disconnected
oh did he get a screenshot nope no time
so the good news for Gary McKinnon was
his suspicions were approved correct the
bad news the US government was on to him
[Music]
is this a UFO
and he's smiling at me and he says I
can't tell you that what I knew he meant
was it was but he couldn't tell me
so I said what are you going to do with
this information
and he said well we always have to
airbrush them out before we sell them to
the public
and I was just amazed that they had a
protocol in place or getting rid of UFO
pictures
Gary McKinnon stumbled onto more
evidence of what he saw in the file of
non-terrestrial officers evidence of a
secret space program within the U.S
military and this secret space program
isn't new there were clues about it
going back over 50 years in the 1960s
the U.S Air Force had a program that ran
in parallel with NASA's Mercury Gemini
and Apollo programs it was called the
manned orbiting laboratory or mol the
mol program had its own facilities and
its own staff they had uniforms and
spacesuits but they were completely
different from NASA's so there'd be no
confusion that the mol employees worked
for a completely different program the
operation was so secret that not even
the wives knew what their husbands were
working on and wives don't need to know
nothing what happens in orbit stays in
orbit you've been divorced how many
times three cheap the mol program
was created to develop a spy station in
space but it was canceled by President
Richard Nixon in 1969. what was it right
but with Gary McKinnon stumbled onto was
something far bigger than some cold war
spy program after Gary found the
cigar-shaped UFO on the NASA computer
and got caught U.S officials began to
pressure the UK to help track him down
in early 2002 Gary was arrested and
charged with 97 counts of causing damage
to U.S intelligence assets and he was
accused of doing eight hundred thousand
dollars worth damage the U.S government
claimed he hacked into dozens of
military computers and 16 NASA computers
they claimed he altered and deleted
files and that his activities were in
the U.S government's words intentional
and calculated to influence and affect
the US government by intimidation and
coercion these charges were very
aggressive clearly the US government was
concerned about what Gary found so they
wanted to make an example of him and
make sure no one else would ever try to
access a single document mentioning UFOs
Gary McKinnon spent 10 years defending
himself against these charges and trying
to stay in the UK if he were charged in
the United States he'd be facing up to 7
years in federal prison the media picked
up the story but downplayed the UFO
connection McKinnon was described as a
hacker trying to harm the Pentagon the
only major publication to mention the
UFO side of the story was the UK Daily
Mail Gary said this publicity is one of
the things that saved him eventually his
case landed on the desk of UK Home
Secretary Theresa May would eventually
go on to be prime minister she ruled
that McKinnon could not be taken back to
the U.S because he suffered from
Asperger's now Gary McKinnon did break
the law there's no disputing that but he
also did the U.S a favor using the
hacker named solo he sent messages to
U.S agencies telling them their security
was weak he felt he was morally
Justified I thought if this technology
really does exist
it should be used for the good of all of
us you know
um free energy
um or at least very cheap if this has
been kept secret why because obviously
that'll be used against people if it's
being kept secret rather than furthering
Humanity
um but at the time there was a very
popular phrase banded about called
heating or eating old age pensioners had
to choose whether to pay for their
heating or pay to have food and then sit
on their chair with a blanket and eat
their food Gary McKinnon's case finally
ended in 2012 and he became a celebrity
in the UFO Community he had exposed or
at least said it exposed government
knowledge of an alien presence but his
case proved there was something much
more Sinister going on this wasn't
something as simple as the US government
covering up UFOs this was proof that
there was a highly organized secret
space program in place this program has
a staff of thousands it has a fleet of
spaceships it has weapons more advanced
than anything currently in use and this
program has a name solar Warden
[Music]
another incident I knew someone in
quarantine with the Apollo Astronauts he
told me that the Apollo astronaut saw
crap on the moon when we landed the
astronauts are told to keep this quiet
they're not allowed to talk about it
at the same time Gary McKinnon was
snooping NASA's servers rumors were
going around about a secret space
program named solar Warden solar warden
came out of the program called the
Strategic Defense Initiative but this
was a Reagan Era defense program
nicknamed Star Wars by the media now
this program has multiple space
platforms similar to aircraft carriers
its mission is to scan the solar system
for unauthorized alien intrusions and
Report those intrusions to the U.S space
force according to the rumors the U.S
and other nations have treaties that say
only a small number of alien visitors
are allowed on Earth at a time but the
aliens had been breaking the treaties
for decades at Torrance everybody knows
those damn arturians can't be trusted
that sounds kind of racist save it for
Twitter
touche as The Story Goes Reagan was
briefed on the aliens by military and
civilian leaders he immediately became
determined to protect the Earth from the
alien presence now how do we know this
Reagan said so himself in 2007 Harper
Collins published the Reagan Diaries
this book is an insight into the
president's daily life in the White
House his entries aren't written like a
memoir they're just thoughts that Reagan
jotted down throughout the day and on
page 334 dated June 11 1985 the
president made the following entry lunch
with five top space scientists it was
fascinating space truly is the Last
Frontier and some of the developments
they're in are like science fiction
except they are real I learned that our
shuttle capacity is such that we could
orbit 300 people whoa to give a little
big one slip eh he sure did now if you
know the space program this entry makes
no sense the maximum capacity of a NASA
space shuttle is eight people at the
time the entire fleet was only four even
if all the shuttles were used at the
same time which they never were that's
only 32 people so what's Reagan talking
about later people suggested Reagan
might not have been talking about space
shuttles at all maybe he was referencing
a program that was supposedly canceled
in 1979 a program to develop a space
plane called star acre oh like the James
Bond movie no that was Moonraker oh
right uh hey you know that girl at the
end of the movie had braces yep I
thought so too but she didn't that's a
Mandela effect can't get my brain to
accept it I can't either anyway the star
raker unlike the shuttle could carry a
lot of people it was bigger than a 747
it could carry a payload of 200 000
pounds more than enough to put 300
people on a space platform so it's
possible that Reagan was right and solar
Warden Is Real at least technically the
first reference to a secret space
program with the name solar Warden is
from early 2006 an anonymous post
appeared on a bulletin board called the
open Minds forum we have a space Fleet
which is codenamed solar Ward there were
as of 2005 eight ships equivalent to
aircraft carriers and 43 protectors
which are space blades I've almost lost
recently to an accident Mars orbit while
it was attempting to resupply the
multinational Colony within Mars This
base was established in 1964 by American
and Soviet teamwork not everything is as
it seems we have visited all the planet
in our solar system at a distance of
course except Mercury we've landed on
Pluto and a few moons these shits
contain Personnel from many countries
and have sworn an oath to the world
government the technology came from back
engineering alien disc wreckage and at
times with alien assistance for a few
years solar Warden flew mostly under the
radar in UFO circles but in 2012 solar
Warden was back in November of that year
a Huffington Post article by reporter
Darren perks was the first major news
article about solar Warden it was also
the first to tie in the story of Gary
McKinnon the article claimed that the
program began in 1980 and operates under
the U.S naval Network and space
Operations Command the nnsoc the space
fleet has eight massive carriers each
over 600 feet long each carrier is
staffed by 300 people and protected by
about 40 Scout ships and these ships are
used to intercept alien Intruders
according to the report there are
permanent multinational bases on the
moon and Mars that are supplied by the
carriers so that's why we never went
back to the Moon right at least not
publicly Darren perks personally
investigated the solar Warden story in
2010 he was contacted by a whistleblower
in the U.S Department of Defense this
contact confirmed that solar Warden is
real while conducting a foia freedom of
information request with the dod
Department of Defense in 2010 I had a
much unexpected response by email from
them which read about an hour ago I
spoke to a NASA rep who confirmed this
was their program and it was terminated
by then President Obama he also informed
me that it was not a joint program with
the dod the national rep informed me
that you should be directed to the
Johnson Space Center for your manager so
assuming perks wasn't lying the email
response clearly indicated solar Warden
existed or something like it did but was
canceled by President Obama in the early
2000s perks never followed up on his
original art vehicle and as you might
expect neither NASA nor the dod has ever
mentioned it so if all we have a report
from Anonymous people that's not much
proof of solar Warden but in 2007 we'd
get more evidence and this time they're
pictures
in 2007 a British amateur astronomer
named John Leonard walson started using
a new technique film the night sky by
attaching special equipment to his
telescope he records objects in visible
infrared and UltraViolet spectrums he
then takes the clearest frame from each
band and combines them this process is
called luminous layering wallson first
used the technique to view the space
shuttle and the International Space
Station and experts confirmed that his
technique works but things got really
weird when he started recording videos
of stars in the sky Watson discovered
that many of the stars are not stars at
all they're in fact massive highly
reflective space platforms exactly the
type that solar Warden uses some
platforms have solar panels other have
what looks like weapons attached to the
structures he said some of the objects
look like spaceships from Star Trek that
might be used by the Federation or
Klingons oh oh what a toilet paper and
Captain Kirk have in common please don't
they both fly past Uranus and wipe out
the Klingons oh
Wilson seemed to be confirming the
presence of a vast Fleet in the space
above us exactly a solar Warden
Believers claimed oh the government
probably hates this guy yet they sure do
not long after releasing his images the
infamous black helicopters appeared
flying very close to his house
[Music]
foreign
said that he was even being intimidated
by what he called a government goon and
they even got physical at one point but
there's more to solar Warden than just
questionable videos taken with a
telescope in the mid-1980s rumors
emerged of a secret government project
codename Aurora Aurora is a
triangle-shaped space plane the program
was even covered in aviation magazines
now there weren't many UFO sightings
described as triangles before the 80s
but now this is a common type of UFO
also during this time the British
Ministry of Defense opened up a highly
classified office dedicated to quietly
investigating UFOs one of its employees
was Nick Pope Nick said on the wall of
the main office was a large photograph
of an object known as The Calvin UFO
which was taken near Calvin England on
August 4th 1990. the original photo has
disappeared but it depicted an 80 foot
long wedge or diamond shaped object in
the sky being chased Away by a Harrier
jet this happened in front of Civilian
Witnesses who took the picture using the
Recollections of people who had seen the
actual photos computer artists later
recreated the image and that was the
last anyone heard about the UFO photo
but in 2022 a former British
intelligence officer named Craig Lindsay
released a scan of what he claimed was
the authentic original Calvin UFO photo
it showed the diamond-shaped object the
Harrier jet and the fence in the
foreground almost exactly matching the
artist's rendering of the scene
Lindsay's photo was confirmed by experts
to be authentic so it was real well no
well maybe
probably not the photo paper was
authentic and typical for the 90s but
the originals are supposed to be color
photos Lindsay's is black and white also
the exact location of the original
Calvin UFO photo was found and the
background didn't match there should be
Hills and Fields and trees in the
background and there just aren't now
supporters say you can't see the
background in the photos because it's
too foggy but weather reports say the
day the photo was taken was perfectly
clear so whatever Lindsay's photo is
it's probably not one of the originals
but the original photograph was taken by
two civilian hikers and for some strange
reason their identities are classified
until the year 2076 and the photos do
match the craft developed by the Aurora
project and there are plenty of
witnesses who say that's exactly what
the Calvin UFO really is so unless the
original photos are found or we can
speak to the hikers we may never know
what the object really was now Skeptics
of solar Warden say it's too difficult
to keep such a large program secret that
people who were part of the program
would talk and they're right people
would talk in fact they did
the Air Force official response to any
reports of uh that nature is that we
have no such program but there's a
growing body of evidence that seems to
indicate otherwise the Hypersonic
aircraft to a speed of around 4 000
miles per hour if you look at it from
underneath the what you see is a perfect
Triangle really quite unlike anything
else has ever been flown and according
to Bill Sweetman there's the Air Force's
secret test base in southern Nevada
called Groom Lake if there is something
going on a very large scale and simply
denying that anything like Aurora exists
leaves wide open the question of what's
going on there still the Air Force says
it knows nothing
shortly after the solo Warden story
emerged several witnesses came forward
each claiming to have been a part of the
secret space program one of these was
Laura Eisenhower great-granddaughter of
President Dwight Eisenhower she said
that at an early age she'd been
kidnapped and sent to other planets she
claimed she was involved in a war with
an alien species called the archons
Andrew vasiago was another whistleblower
he said he was recognized at an early
age as an ideal fit for a secret space
program he claimed that he used a
teleporter not a spaceship to travel to
Mars on many occasions and while on Mars
he engaged in armed conflict with alien
species and by 2015 other whistleblowers
confirmed their involvement not just in
a vague secret space program but
specifically in a program called solar
Warden Corey Goode said he was removed
from his old life in the 1980s then
reverse aged 20 years and recruited into
a secret military program I'd like to
reverse stage 20 years you and me both
pal
now Corey Goode described a friendly
race of blue avians that were part of a
super Federation of aliens the
Federation is trying to help the human
race fight off Alien Invaders including
a reptilian race is it people from out
of space yep so most of these unwanted
entrances into our solar system would be
more
small groups of ETS or single craft that
are trying to be sneaky right a little
kind of slip in Marauder groups that
would come in and do hit and runs to
come in and take things and leave
illicit people are crafty so very very
crafty good said some people part of the
secret space program are trying to push
full disclosure trying to force the
alien presence into the open by doing
flybys of the International Space
Station and popping up on photos and
videos but disclosure still hasn't
happened and solar Warden is virtually
unknown to most of the population so
either there's no such thing as solar
Warden or a secret space program or it
is true and our solar system is a far
more dangerous place than any of us
could have possibly imagined
solar Warden and the secret space
program is a major branch of ufology and
because of social media it's becoming
more mainstream solar Warden is covered
everywhere from YouTube to tick tock to
the occasional mainstream news story
but is it true no well maybe
um some of it Gary McKinnon is certainly
a real person but he says he doesn't
know anything about solar Warden or how
he got associated with it he never saw
that name on any document or image that
he accessed it seems that the article by
Darren perks in 2012 is what connected
Gary to the solar Ward mythology and
it's easy to understand the connection
the picture of the ship McKinnon saw
sounds a lot like the carrier Platforms
in solar Warden stories but even if Gary
McKinnon saw a picture of a UFO and I
believe he did it's a leap to go from
one photo to a huge secret space program
conspiracy now other aspects of the
story The carriers the fighters the
large Crews and the guarding of the
solar system these sound like the plots
of well-known science fiction books and
TV shows for example a spaceship moon
bases and Fighters that monitor the
solar system come straight from a 1970
British TV show called UFO who is that
The Groovy one with the moon girls in
short skirts and silver cat suits and
the purple wigs that's the one
mention the short skirts you did
it is a great show he's really uh he's
such a good day I always say I always
like the uh well we're waiting he's a
good uh Canyon okay snap out of it sorry
the show also featured Sid the space
Intruder detector its job was to scan
near Earth space for alien Intruders
just like solar Warden and some of the
eyewitnesses like Corey Goode have been
exposed as froths he was forced to
testify under oath that he made the
whole thing up especially the part about
the blue avians helping to protect the
Earth well maybe he made that
but lizard people are definitely real
eyewitnesses like Laura Eisenhower and
Andrew basiago may be telling the truth
but their stories are a hodgepodge of
every science fiction Trope you can
think of time travel teleportation Zero
Point Energy and the list goes on now
I'm not saying they're lying but I am
saying they both tell very convoluted
Stories the only aspect of solar Warden
that holds up to any scrutiny is Gary
McKinnon's personal testimony but
unfortunately that's all we have his
word now think of the logistics involved
in something like solar warden in order
for it to work every nation on Earth
would have to be involved Russia China
the US and really every industrialized
country on earth is aware when any other
country launches a rocket of any kind
you couldn't put a fleet's worth of
equipment into space without somebody
noticing you'd also have to constantly
be sending food and water and air into
space to resupply the fleet or they
raise their own livestock in space and
they grow vegetables with Hydroponics
what do you know about Hydroponics let's
just stay in college I was very uh
industrious
so if solar Warden does exist that would
mean every nation on Earth has set aside
their differences and come together for
a common goal that's actually a nice
thought unfortunately that common goal
is protecting the human race from
destruction by an alien invasion now
that's terrifying so I don't know if
solar Warden is real but when I think
about its purpose I really hope it isn't
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is AJ that's hecklefish
greetings Earthly this has been the
y-files and if you had fun or learned
anything do him a favor and like
subscribe comment and share that stuff
really makes hecklefish happy now like
most topics we cover on the channel
today's was recommended by you and if
there's a story you'd like to see or
learn more about go to the yfiles.com
tips and special thanks to our patrons
who make this channel possible
especially when we get demonetized for
no reason like last week
if you'd like to be part of a great
Community Check out the Y files on
Discord it's a lot of fun and free to
join but if you'd like to support the
channel consider becoming a member on
patreon or grab something from the Wi-Fi
store
the coffee mugs a completely 100
Festival that's true until next time be
safe be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
wow
all right
foreign